ewan mcgregor and mary elizabeth
winstead met and fell in love while
playing a couple in the 2017 fargo
series and now they're newlyweds the two
got married just last month and they've
got a baby together you know um as
parents sometimes you have to use jedi
mind tricks on your kids well this baby
is gonna grow up with a jedi master you
and his back is obi-wan kenobi in the
new disney plus series of the same name
matt cohen got all the details and the
scoop on his reunion with hayden
christensen
[Music]
you and hayden on screen together talk
to me a little bit about working with
him i love hayden you know there's
special people in your life as you go
along
your life and he's one of those to me
hayden was just 19 years old when e.t
first met him it was three days after
he'd been cast as anakin skywalker the
young jedi knight who eventually becomes
darth vader it's insanity you know i
grew up on the stuff
well 17 years after he last played the
part hayden's returning to the star wars
universe in the disney plus limited
series obi-wan kenobi debuting tomorrow
ewan mcgregor is the jedi master tasked
with keeping a young luke skywalker safe
from vader in this prequel i've never
quite seen a crew
react the way they reacted when he came
on set for the first time as vader
[Music]
i was like why is there so many people
here today there's people standing all
over the set and then peyton walks out
in the suit and i was like oh of course
that's why everyone's here everyone's
here to see this
[Music]
you